[Music]
well hey everybody it's Friday night
hooray to go out my favorite show of the
week well in a couple of hours going out
in a couple hours yeah we're going it's
momentum Mor tonight so that's where
we're going going to the club yeah going
to the club and Jenna is looking
fantastic right now she's looking hot as
[__] Dave is here and says uh Jen always
looks hot as [__] man I'm going to show
you guys I do don't I I'm going to get
the porn except when I first except when
I first wake up but admittedly I don't
nobody looks good when you're waking up
one time I rolled over and I I said who
does that say you'd look like Oliver re
yes I is woken up here with Oliver Reed
she had a [__] face on she had a
[__] face on her face to be fair you
said my expression look like Oliver re
but I was still pretty
offended she was [__] her face was
[__]
like she looked pissed off as a
[__] you probably woke me up or
some [__] she looked like oler she
looked like Oliver Reed from [__]
burnt offerings and [__] mean and
[__] I got laid anyway though well you
don't you always yeah like I said you
prob she wasn't mean she was just waking
up because the light was on her face she
cuz look I sleep with cuz Tom yeah he
not only has to sleep with noise well no
he has he has headphones now yeah but um
he also sleeps with kind of like some
lights in the room and I can't stand
that it has to be dark so I have like
this little blankie that I just like
fold and put over my eyes because I
can't [__] sleep yeah you know what I
mean and then like you know he'll
usually leave the blinds open so the
kitties can sit there and look out
because they like to look out the
windows so it's like as soon as the sun
comes up it's like and it's going to
like wake me up and I'm like [__] that
[__] you got to see what she's wearing
you get just stand oh okay oh Allison
said killer Nails Jenny thank you I yeah
I told him like Tom got me these on
Sheen or Teo or something
and um I told him I said okay but I'm
going to wear these tonight but you're
going to have to do everything for me
cuz I'm going to be completely useless
with these [__] Nails on I'm not
going to be able to open the car door
I'm not going to be able to like open
the beer can I'm not going to be able to
do anything yeah you got to see this
dress you got okay I don't think I've
worn this one out before no because I
was like looking I was cleaning up my um
my my Whata call it out
there super classy but yeah wait can you
see it yeah yeah there we go see it's
kind of like other ones I got but my god
dude you just knock the mous out there
yeah it's all right he's
getting that angle man
yeah show that boot yeah I got my [__]
these are my these are old come the
light here my old spiky
boots I think some of the Spikes have
actually fallen off over the years but
that's okay they still shiny shiny shiny
boots of leather shiny leather in the
dark dark yeah yeah yeah look you
knocked the mouse off the thing any wor
better that Mouse well I need it hold on
hold on hold on hold on wait hold on
hold on hold I just got to put the
camera in there hold on hold hold on
putting up the camera oh my God hold on
is it my is it my turn
no
[__] oh I thought you were going to like
show everybody your crotch oh no no I'm
not going to thirst trap that bad last
time I got last time I got paid for
thirst
trap well now I got to get the mouse
that you knocked off after all these
shenanigans
but yeah what were we talking about so
yeah so it's really not I mean you know
I kind of wake up cranky and then he
says what oh dude oh oh my God it's so
early and you're already like showing
your under I didn't even I thought you
said you were G to do that I ain't
thirst
[Laughter]
tra oh my goodness look at you and
demonetized that's okay you're a boy you
can get away with
it
yeah Tammy said Jenny should have burnt
your offerings yeah right I was just
kind of like I was like I can't believe
you just [__] said that to me see
your face looks just like [__] oh
[__] Oliver Reed right now [__] shoes
like
this yeah like I said I was probably
cranky cuz you probably woke me up or
some [__] much like I tell you what I
don't know what Lil pooky's problem is
the last couple days but Pooky has been
jumping all over me at like 6 and in the
morning yeah for the last couple nights
w w me up mama yeah wakes me up mama
what the [__] she's crawling around my
head and like laying across my chest and
she I'm like what is your problem she's
stepping on her like this like she's got
I got to tell you something oh my God
yeah yeah and I like what is it and I
was like Pooky stop it she's looking at
me like no I got no no no this is
important I have to tell her something
[__] ridiculous I'm like what is it I
I can't figure out what it is well the
first day that she did it we thought
that it was maybe okay so Pooky is
scared of the garbage truck so if she
can hear the garbage truck coming down
the street or see the garbage truck out
the window she flips the [__] out she
was like that at our old house too so we
thought that that's what it was the
first day like cuz she probably heard
the garbage truck like early in the
morning and she was like oh my God it's
a monster like Mommy help me you know
what I mean I mean she jumps on Tom all
the time yeah she jumps on his nuts she
jumps like lays across his chest but
it's like she doesn't usually no poke no
oh speaking of poy yeah don't tear up
from shoes she's like what she forgets
she's like oh okay don't do
it yeah murder Hornet said we getting
crazy in here tonight yeah already yeah
that's okay that's my favorite kind of
show Pooky it's okay you're kind of in
trouble but not really don't you want
the shoes you know better she's like do
[Laughter]
I but uh but yeah so let's see where was
I big little says he's going to go to
mannequins yeah well it's Friday night
he always goes to mannequins on Friday
like I said we we got we got the men
yeah we got momentos the last one before
Christmas yeah I think this the last one
of year probably yeah we'll see how that
goes yeah man I'm out of ice already
look at this [__] I mean to be fair
I made that drink like a while
back so it's kind of
melty Oracle says oh I have an
announcement I have officially won both
Hanukkah and Christmas oh my god um
because I got all the family presents
out last Saturday and they've all
arrived holy [__] you were like so
organized I haven't bought a single
[__]
thing not a single thing I don't buy a
lot of I buy Tom some
stuff um I buy stuff for his mom I'm
getting some stuff for my sister um I
get stuff for the cats but that's
usually the extent of it you know what I
mean cuz I don't have a [__] ton of
money
so most of my family like we decided
it's like hey we're not going to like go
crazy and buy each other's [__] you know
what I mean I don't even know what I
want for Christmas to be honest what do
you want for Christmas
Tom World Peace
no um I already I already know sex
sty
um already got a bunch of stuff coming
your
way um you do
yeah the um that you didn't tell me
about no oh sneaky no most of it's stuff
that you need You' mentioned already
okay look at you being sneaky like I
said I feel kind of bad I like but I
don't know cuz cuz I know like Tom is a
very practical person and it's like he's
like don't buy me [__] unless cuz I for
unless I ask for it because it's like
he's not
going so usually I'm just like send me
link to what you want and I'll get it
because otherwise I don't want to like I
could use a uh primary arms uh Red Dot
site I can show you which one of didn't
I get you one of those last year yeah I
need another one oh it's for it's for a
different rifle oh okay I got you it's
for a different rifle yeah I was going
to say I'm pretty sure I bought you one
of those for Christmas last year it's um
a replica or something that looks a lot
like the Optics that were used on '90s
AR15s I'm building what's
called The Blood Diamond carbine replica
there was a movie that had what was it
River Phoenix in it oh yeah River
Phoenix called blood blood diamonds wait
was that no I thought was that River
Phoenix was he in blood no it was um
wasn't it Leonardo Deca
Leonardo I saw that on ph died I saw
that on an airplane yeah it was good
actually I wouldn't mind watching it
again when I wasn't like 37,000 ft I
want to see it I've never seen it oh
it's good you probably you'd probably
like it but I've seen the uh the AR-15
that he had and I saw the the the scene
that it's taken
from and it's
uh I'm building a replica of that I had
already have most of it I just build in
a because I have it for other rifles I
had to build the upper receiver and it's
it's got a rare 90s stuff on it but they
do make some stuff now that is kind of
inspired by that '90s stuff it looks
like it it's actually better than what
they what we had in the '90s
it's about 100 bucks proba that's not
bad yeah it's not that it's not real
expensive yeah I think that's a little
bit less than the one I got last year
yeah less than that one then the uh the
other one that you got that was a Sig
Romeo 4 yeah that's battle ready Red Dot
optic basically either got you that for
Christmas or your birthday I can't
remember birthday I think yeah maybe
birthday this one's a lighter weight one
it looks like it's like something that
we would have had in the
90s and it's a it's an xm177 it's a
AR-15 Carbine with a 10inch barrel I
already got all
that to get the legal length of 16 I got
a dummy suppressor on there a dummy
sound suppressor it's not really
suppressed it's not a silencer but it
looks like it he didn't have it in the
movie in the movie he had a like a
little three and a half inch flash
suppressor but it would be too short
legally you know what I mean I'd have to
register it as a short barrel rifle I
going go through that
problem and all that Barrel link thing
is up in the air right now they're
challenging in the Supreme Court that
was something that came out of the 20s
there's no reason why a rifle has to
have 60in Barrel it could have whatever
inch whatever length you want on it it
shouldn't
matter um and another thing is they want
to make
suppressors um
liberalized suppressors are not
silencers people have been
brainwashed uh by action
movies that suppressors make weapons
Silent they don't you suppress AR-15
it's still louder than a 9mm you
suppress a 9mm it's it's still louder
than a 22 you don't need a license for a
22 because it's quiet not that
quiet you can suppress a 22 and you
wouldn't be able to hear it in the Next
Room and but it doesn't matter because
you could take a 22 and shoot a person
with a 22 and their neighbors wouldn't
hear it and people in other rooms
wouldn't know what that was so it didn't
matter if there was a suppressor there
or not you know I could take an AR-15
rifle and shoot it in this house and our
neighbors wouldn't know so suppressors
don't have anything to do with crime or
hiding the fact that things are shot it
just so you don't have to wear hearing
protection it's a muffler like a muffler
on a car same [__]
thing yeah Oracle saying not only she
got all the gifts and stuff like that
but she said all but two of them were
hand knitted by her herself Oracle oh
okay holy [__] yeah you are winning okay
like I said I'm way behind I haven't
looked at anything and I feel really bad
about it cuz holy [__] it's already
December 8th uh yeah where is the time
going like the older you get like just
[__] yeah Dave says me and the wife
have been needing a new bed yeah we need
one we need one too um today I bought an
awesome adjustable bed with all the
whistles split King oo nice yeah friend
of M little swo had a king king-sized
bed yeah you know Matt yeah Matt and he
basically said I could have it if I
could pick it up I didn't have any way
to go get it yeah we don't have a truck
don't have a truck he doesn't have a
truck either cuz he was selling it for
what like 60 bucks or something yeah he
said I could just have it oh really yeah
he says if you come here and get it you
have we desperately need a new bed yeah
and I said I don't have a truck the bed
we have we just inherited it it's like
secondhand and is one of the most
uncomfortable things I've ever shitty
bed and you know we haven't really
um that Old King that we had we haven't
we haven't really been kind to it
so so it's kind of like it's kind of not
in the best shape still we [__] that bed
up we had we got to where we when we
have sex we got to go out to the living
room now yeah yeah it's yeah so we
don't hanging H hanging out the [__]
window and [__] I mean the window wasn't
open
but it's night they can't see unless
they have binoculars yeah the neighbors
aren't that close but if they had
binoculars they could probably see what
was going on they're too far but I figur
they're probably not looking in here
even if they were they get a free show
it's just free
it's we shot a couple videos last week
they're [__] good shot three of them
they were in public yeah pretty I'm
still like I the one of them the one
that I did in the car while we were
driving I like that one cuz I shot that
one yeah the cam I had a hard time
driving and doing camera angles and [__]
at the same time yeah well yeah you
shouldn't do that because you got to
drive but we did shoot some outside cuz
we wanted we wanted to do more um public
stuff because apparently that sells
pretty well yeah because it's not it's a
smaller Niche like not a lot not a lot
of people do it yeah it's fun and it is
actually fun to do because there's
always just kind of like this we found
because you could get caught like at any
moment so she was out on a dock had her
out on a dock right like out in the open
out in the open at a lake there's houses
all around yeah um there's a bch park
bench there yeah we were just like out
there was parking lot right there yeah
all open yeah it was good she loved it
it was fun it was fun yeah you and I was
I mean there was nobody else there there
nobody else there and he was keeping
watch I was keeping
watch I had a view of the road into the
place so if somebody were to come down
the road it' be plain of warning yeah
it'd be like hey like right straighten
up
yeah you know I mean yeah we were doing
that outside actually driving was funny
because fcking oncoming traffic yeah
yeah but they it was funny so I was
watching nobody even noticed well that's
the thing it's I you always kind of
think about that because you do feel
like everyone's looking at you because
you're doing something you're not
supposed to be doing but the thing about
it is like when I'm driving around in my
car I don't [__] ever look at anybody
in the other cars they could be doing
God knows what in there I don't [__]
know yeah and there was no way no way no
way anybody could come up alongside of
us yeah cuz it was just like a like a
two-lane
highway but the only time we kind of
like stop was when we were going through
like the traffic circles and stuff but
yeah yeah we drove through like
neighborhoods and [__] like that she's
had fun it was fun I I like that a lot
who knew I'm like a little bit of an
exhibitionist I don't want to get
arrested though but you know what I mean
but it's still kind of fun you just you
just tell the C no we making content
he'd be like making content that's all
right I mean as long as the cop was cool
they'd be like you know it's not it's
not like there's any children present or
anything like that you know Florida cops
don't give a [__] just as long as it's
not [__] egregious yeah well like I
said and we're not doing anything we're
not doing it on purpose like making
people they're not making people see
watch it or anything like that like I
would rather not yeah you know people
see us we're just kind of like you know
what I mean like if somebody comes along
we're just going to be like hey we're
not doing anything you know what I mean
um murder hor said uh LOL don't send me
no more videos it's weird from this
Chanel yeah he was talking about hey man
you know don't take this weird never
mind I F give a you're not I'm not
goingon to tell this
business dude I sent that I sent you I
sent you stuff so you can watch it yeah
it's I'm not I'm not weird about it I'm
not he's said you don't you get jealous
no no I sent it to you so you eny wor
about it we're not worried about it yeah
don't worry about it like I said it's
just I mean we just make it's a product
we make we make [__] so other people can
watch you can watch it or not it's like
it doesn't matter I'm not weirded out by
it I don't really think about it all
that much to be honest with you yeah
it's not really a big deal when you're
making it yeah I just kind of make it
cuz it's fun but you know what I mean
yeah most of the time sometimes it's a
pain in the ass but that's all
that's just funny to tell that
anym sh he'll ask for some
[Laughter]
more yeah you don't um you're you're not
a a very jealous person no not not about
stuff like that not about stuff like
that no no I'm more like uh you know
what I mean
[__] you know if you just ran off
left me on my own or something you know
well I would never I would never do that
though I'm not I would they got you know
like I said we know couples that do that
right you stay here I'm gonna go out uh
with [__] Susie I'll be back later
you know going to the club with her I
would not like that yeah yeah yeah I
don't want you to do that and I would
it's kind of rude yeah that's what I
mean that is very rude but they don't
seem to care I guess not well some
people don't but yeah gu it kind of
bored with each other I guess yeah D
yeah you get out of here if it works for
them that's fine but it's like I would
never do that cuz like I said we yeah we
know some people that they're married
they're married yeah but and they you
know they do open [__] like they'll do
stuff like all together like they go to
swingers clubs and stuff like that but
it's like then they'll do stuff like on
their own well like he does I don't know
about her but um she probably does too
but he's just like hey I'm gonna go to
the club with what's her name bye she's
chilled out though so she probably
probably doesn't you like you'd have to
ask her I guess yeah I'm not really sure
I don't know how I'd Broach that topic
but um I just ask her yeah we don't see
them all that often they come out every
now and then but see the thing is is
that he'll run off with these
chicks but that one time when I [__]
was like
uh you know asked her if she wanted to
work with you do a scene or something
like that I had to go through him he he
had to be there see that seems a little
problematic like wait hold on you're
banging us other broad and she's not
there why do you have to be there like
why do you have to be there right what
you think I'm going to do something with
her that's my ex-girlfriend yeah you
know what I mean I've been
there you know we just wanted her to do
stuff with me yeah make a good video
like she's cool yeah I like yeah I love
her but that's yeah yeah she's your
ex-girlfriend but it's not I know that
sounds weird but it's not weird we're
all friends she's a lovely person yeah
we're all friends and you know and I've
known her a long time yeah so yeah we
been but then I don't know there's just
this whole kind of thing I so I do kind
of feel like I don't know there's like a
weird double standard there I feel like
but what do I know I don't know I don't
know what's going on you know we don't
really think of it that way I guess yeah
it just seems very strange
just gos it's yeah that's that's our own
like sexual orientation is God but well
yeah well and that's the thing too it's
just kind of like I would never I could
never
imagine just like being like hey I'm
going to go to the club with you know
whoever the [__] some random ass dude
yeah you find somebody to go hang out
with and just leave you at home I would
never do that in a million years why
would you want why would I want to do
that it wouldn't even cross my mind no
me neither well it's just kind of I'm
always kind of one of those people I
don't know maybe I'm a little
oldfashioned and stuff but I'm just kind
of like like well I wouldn't have like
gone out with you and like married you
if I didn't want to hang out with you
yeah yeah it's weird that's all but like
I said other people are different so I'm
not judging I'm just
saying it's like I actually like hanging
out with you yeah we were kind of
inseparable even when we were dating
other people when we were just friends
yeah that's what's weird it's just kind
of like we were both kind of casually
seeing other people it we're just
hanging out but we would just hang out
constantly too like we'd be going out of
the club actually one time I don't know
if I I don't remember if I ever told you
this or not but um I was on I went to
the club with some what was that dude's
name some dude I kind of sort of
casually H offand dated for like a month
or something and we were at
iar and he got upset because I was
spending too much time with you and he's
just like why don't you just leave with
him then like he got like all upset
about it remember I remember that one
yeah yeah so who was that um what's his
name John something I don't remember
that that guy yeah he wasn't around all
that much he was just some dude that I
think I just picked him up at iar one
night was it Halloween I don't even
remember I don't remember but it was it
was a while back and it was kind of like
a one night stand thing but then like we
kind of just hung out like a little
while but then um he was looking for a
wife pretty much and I was like bro yeah
settle down you know what I mean um and
I think he didn't like it that I hung
out with you too much right I think that
was that Normie guy what he was a little
bit Normy I remember that kind of L like
like a little truck driver or something
well yeah I don't even remember what he
looked like Hest remember or not little
truck driver it was a long time ago he
just kind of a kind of a I want to say a
redneck but no it wasn't a he wasn't a
redneck but he was he was a little bit
Normy though like a Normy yeah he was
kind of Normy I think I vaguely remember
that dude yeah and so but yeah like he
got mad because he didn't seem to really
give a [__] [__] though you're like yeah
that dude yeah not really yeah right I
was kind of upset when he's just like
yeah whatever and he just kind of like
blew me off but I was upset for like an
hour and then it was okay right you know
what I
mean cuz I was just kind of like what
someone doesn't love me [__] off you
know what I mean it was that kind of
thing just I guess yeah he yeah like I
said he didn't like it that I H hang out
that I hung out with you too
much okay at the club that or was it
yeah yeah yeah at iar okay you were
spending too much time hanging out with
me you weren't yeah yeah well and the
thing about it
wasn't we were we were hanging with the
same group of friends that's what I mean
and it's like I think he didn't like
that because I mean he went to iar too
like every now and then but he wasn't
like kind of the the core like goth
people right you know what I mean he was
just kind of one of the outliers so I
think that he didn't like it that I
trying to take you out of there yeah
that that I was not only hanging out
with you but I was hanging because I
knew a lot of people there so I was just
kind of like hey what TR monize right
right right so it was that kind of
situation and I was like and I was just
kind of like me I I don't know if I like
that so much so it was that kind of
thing and see that's why a lot of goth
people don't date outside of the goth
out of our race out of our
race go well because you get involved
with a normie and then all of a sudden
you're doing Normie [__] all the time
and they don't want you to do the goth
[__] anymore well do you really have to
wear that do you really have to go to
that place it's going to go in that
direction nobody wants that it's just
really tiresome so it's like I've
learned a long experience they're going
to take you to places where they play
music that's intolerable that's another
thing that too yeah they're going to
take you to a lot of places where I'm
just kind of like please just kill me
now I really don't want to be here
so I can do it for limited amount of
times I can go to the Oasis and hang out
in the [__] biker club and and listen
to Country I hate it though I can put up
with it for a few hours because I know
that it's the that age group and they're
[__] redneck
bikers and that's what they're going to
listen to and then it'll start going
into [__] shitty rap too like a
mixture of country and rap I I don't
understand it but some of it's okay you
know just regular rock or you know Kid
Rock [__] that kind of crap I don't even
really like that like I can tolerate
that but you start getting into like
that new country yeah oh I'm just like
nope
yeah if they're real old if they're real
old they're in there [__] playing the
Eagles and [__] and you know just I mean
I can I can tolerate the Eagles Leonard
Skinner that's a little more of a um of
a crapshoot because I'm pretty sure I've
told the story before but when I lived
in Daytona my next door neighbor was
like the world's biggest Leonard
skinnard fan yeah and I used to work ni
so I wouldn't get home till 3: 4 in the
morning I worked at a newspaper and so I
would want to sleep until at least 10:00
a.m. come on yeah he'd be up at 6:30
7:00 in the morning working in the yard
blaring that same like greatest hits of
Leonard skinnard and singing along yeah
yeah right outside my [__] bedroom
window every godamn morning what I'll do
down there when I have money and I have
money to burn I they I'll [__] drop
[__] $20 on the juke box cuz the juke
box is run by a an
app so I'll be the DJ in at the at the
Oasis I'll play stuff that I like that
they can listen to I'll play you know uh
Billy Idol's [__] new one [__] uh
[__] what's the name of that [__]
he's got a new song that's kind of it's
pretty good um I'll play some old
classic metal Judas Priest and stuff
I'll do some deep purple they they'll
like that play some [__] Motorhead or
something body lik everybody likes
Motorhead yeah I play stuff off the Ace
of Spades or off the overkill album if
it was me I would just play motohead or
Johnny Cash or something like that
because everybody likes that everybody
they actually like Billy Idol they like
yeah I mean I kind of feel like
everybody likes Billy Idol too play
stuff off of like uh the charm he's not
controversial yeah they like him well he
he ended up riding a lot yeah you know
what I mean and I'm trying to remember
that new song that he's got so he's
biker adjacent yeah he's kind of biker
adjacent um um you play White Wedding
they like that one uh which you wouldn't
think they would like white wedding yeah
but it's kind of new wavy but they like
it right but that's also from I mean cuz
some of them are our age even though
they look way older not to be mean but
um you know so that's from their era
just like it's from our era cuz I think
white wedding came out when I was 10 or
11 years old so and then
uh I [__] I freaked all the chicks
out there I call them chicks they're all
their 50s or 60s I played some cure they
[__] loved it they were like yeah
yeah I play Boys Don't Cry they they
knew that one they liked that one that's
pretty cool though so then I started I
started taking them down that path I put
[__] I played [__] aha take Take
On Me they [__] like that I love it
they like that oh yeah so I started
playing playing [__] um yeah so I
started playing what else did I play oh
[__] I just went along down that path I
did [__] Billy Idol's cover of
[__] um um don't you forget about me
yeah yeah they like that one so you
know you can get away with certain
things yeah as long as you don't get too
crazy you don't get too crazy but like I
said I think the last time I was there
okay yeah it's check chick music but
yeah it's okay last time I was there
when we were up there meeting Melissa
and her boyfriend um somebody I don't
know who uh put some real shitty country
music on yeah and I was I was texting
and I I don't think Zach is here but I
was like texting Zach the whole time
being like Oh my God please kill me like
this [__] music is horrible Oracle
said happiness is being married to your
best friend yeah yeah we did real well
we got lucky that way yeah like I said I
I liked you yeah anyway like I said I
just liked hanging out with you and the
way it happened was just like organic we
didn't really like meet each other
thinking that anything was going to go
any we've almost been together 247 for
[__] 13 14 years yeah and that's
another thing it's like it's not even
like I mean we moved we've only fought
like maybe five times yeah in 15 [__]
14 years and it was stupid [__] we were
drunk half the time I feel like every
time we fight it's almost always it's
pretty much always more
drunk drunk I'm my Trend well that too
yeah that didn't help but um but yeah I
kind of
well that well that's the thing it's
just kind of seems
like man it's just it's been such a long
time and it really doesn't seem like
that long a time though no it flew by it
really did because we're having fun yeah
I guess so I guess so the relationship
can't be about the
relationship the relationship has to be
friendship between two people that have
common
goals and yeah wanted to do [__] in the
scene I wanted to make sure she became a
[__] horror writer so I did
everything I could to help her with that
we did the show did a lot of stuff we
just started doing our own thing so when
I met her she was working uh for just
regular
companies and you were in between jobs
and I said Jen we're going to you're
going to write those books you're
talking about we're going to do audio
books and it worked she started selling
audiobooks yeah and [__] she stayed
here and [__] we started making money
off the internet uh it was hard for the
first couple months but we never fell
short of the rent or anything yeah I
mean we had to scrape together some [__]
sometimes but yeah and and we mostly
she's like that now she's an independent
she doesn't have a job job
we we're in the gig economy and you know
yeah my my [__] VA paycheck [__]
helps because it's steady that's always
going to come I can get locked up and
thrown in jail but that [__] will still
come that's why I'm so but [__]
bulletproof like [__] they can lock me
up my money's still coming I just send
it to Jen she'll [__] spend it she'll
pay the rent yeah
so you know which I got lucky you know
Murder hornet in the same situation if
you get [__] service service related
injury the same thing a cop gets you
know I get 85% of my pay and all my
[__] medical yeah that's nice but
what I was going to say is that I was
going back to something you said
earlier yeah with yeah you get cost of
living increases yeah and you got a
little bit of a bump when we got married
got married got extra 200 bucks a month
yeah yeah so um but yeah what you were
saying earlier about us being together
24/7 I think that's another thing too is
I kind of feel like maybe a lot of
couples like you know they work and they
don't see each other like all day and
stuff like that but we are in each
other's faces all the time all day every
day and have been for almost 13 solid
years yeah we'll go into different rooms
sure yeah we're not like ride go out and
go somewh to come back a couple hours
later yeah yeah yeah but yeah so it's
not like we're totally like in each
other's faces like all the time but CU I
have my office and [__] like that and he
like I said he goes out for ride
sometimes or whatever but some
girlfriends I had I could never imagine
that cuz they were just [__] annoying
you know after like a couple days like
man this [__] is [__] annoying but
Jen was never
annoying I'm pretty low-key yeah I
always thought I was like pretty easy to
put up with yeah you know what I mean
because I'm not like super obnoxious and
I'm not loud and you know a lot of you
don't have a lot of you don't have
annoying personality traits a lot of
women have annoying personality traits
yeah well a lot of people have annoying
personality traits I've noticed yeah you
know what Ian
mean like I said I'm pretty lowkey like
I keepy to myself most of the time I'm
pretty quiet another thing is we
understood each other we spoke the same
damn language basically yeah we're
totally different about about most
things that's another yeah it's weird
because we're totally opposite in a lot
of ways in a lot of ways we're totally
opposite but anything happens when we
both see it we both [__] agree oh
yeah that yeah that's [__] up oh yeah
that's cool
yeah right it's really weird like I said
we have like one of the strangest
relationships that I've ever yeah but in
a good way in a good way and we've had
like multiple people tell us that too
yeah so it must be something yeah
different than what most people
experience I guess well thing is is that
she's real different but her differences
don't threaten me you know what I mean
like I don't care that she has a
different opinion what does that do to
do with me her opinion is just different
that's the way she sees it yeah you know
she might be seeing something I'm not
seeing yeah or she's her emphasis is to
look at something from a different
perspective different angle that's fine
I'm not like you know oh I can't hang
out with her she's too Lefty no [__]
you know I'm
[__] I don't I don't really believe
in the left right thing really I think
it's kind of an artificial dichotomy but
there is like a very masculine and a
very feminine and there's a different
kinds of energies that's be a good way
to put it but in General jens's on the
left and I'm kind of more on the right
even though I don't believe in any of
these politics I think politicians are
all Crooks but we still agree on
everything pretty much I mean more or
less yeah not everything but more or
less yeah any differences we have aren't
really important no it's just because
they're just difference between vanilla
and chocolate they're both good it's
just what your preferences are but yeah
they got people today oh I can't go out
with this person they don't agree with
me I've seen them do what the [__] you
talking about what do you want to go out
the clone yourself I mean I can see how
like some people think it is easier I
guess like to hang out with somebody
that just agrees with you on everything
but it's not really that much fun either
you're not going to have much depth in
anything that's true cuz Jen Jen can see
things that I don't see or sometimes
we'll get in a situation where I see it
she doesn't see it I'll [__] save her
that type of [__] you know what I
mean yeah like I'll save this situation
that [__] bad we can't be around
this person yeah you know what I mean it
turns out yeah the person I I got a good
Instinct for evil because I I'm a doctor
I have a doctorate in evil I'm Doctor
evil [__] I I know evil when I see it
I can feel it one of as many doctorates
including many doil including one in his
one in bology yeah
bology yeah
acology acology
bootyologist are bigger they're more
they're more round I just wanted to know
what the difference was that's all just
I I wanted the distinction I knew you'd
come up with something yeah as is what
they had back in the 80s on white
girl well you have an ass impants plants
and little ass and [__] big blonde
perm and [__] big blonde perm holy
[__] oh my
god um oracle's talking about how
awesome Dolly Parton is also go yeah I
love Dolly Parton there's a lot of good
interviews with Dolly Parton [__]
knocking it out of the water she she
seems like a lovely very smart lady very
smart lady and she looks fantastic yeah
yeah she's still good-looking she's a
good-looking old lady yep uh
but in her 20s and her teens even her
30s and 40s she was hot hot little short
Southern ger she's adorable I love her
yeah uh didn't we didn't we review best
little wh house in Texas long ago cuz I
hadn't seen that since I was a kid and I
was like we need to rewatch thisit you
haven't seen best little hor house in
Texas it's a musical we were going on a
whole like Bert Reynolds kind of B
Reynolds Dolly part kind of thing like a
few like several months ago yeah we
ended up
watching in Texas very Southern [__]
very
Southern uh I you know I if I had to do
a study of Bert Reynolds Bert Reynolds
was when I was a kid I remember Bert
Reynolds movies I didn't watch them all
except I remember uh watching mostly
like Cannonball Run yeah smoking a
bandit smoking a bandit I remember those
mostly those were on cable all the
[__] time I must have seen those
movies like 50 million times when I was
a kid yeah they were always on so I was
under the impression that b was more
like a
comedian and I knew he did other kind of
movies but I hadn't really experienced
him so we go back into his catalog and I
watch his [__] white lightning all
right great movie and then Gator which
is part two yeah I thought Gator was
part one and white lightning was part
two no white lightning was part one oh
okay maybe I can't remember and uh then
Malone and then what was the one where
he played the cop in Atlanta had the
paranormal thing his partner was a black
guy remember that he thought you could
make yourself invisible was the name of
that [__] movie they were going
after that serial killer hit
man remember that the black guy seemed
seemingly made himself invisible
remember that when the killer came up on
with a gun and then are you high right
now no why okay cuz I you don't remember
that I don't remember that at all
[__] crazy maybe I'm high you're
high there
was it could be that I'm just having
like a like a me you're having a [__]
mental
block I'll probably remember it like 10
minutes all right
Bert Reynolds is playing a big city cop
in Atlanta in the
80s I think it might have been mid 80s
late 80s you got a black
partner the black partner is telling a
story about how he thought he'd read
something that if you focused
enough that you could you you could
render
yourself invisible I'm going to have to
try that out when these days
yeah and he he saw some he saw some
evidence in it in some kind of
paranormal story that he
heard and at the end of the
movie the Assassin has shot up a bunch
of people he shot the [__] black guy
who was his partner and he was laying
there on the ground the serial killer
comes up to him with a gun and [__]
the black dude starts concentrating and
focusing and then the the guy never
pulls the tri he just walks away like he
didn't see him wait a minute what the
[__] was the name of that moment it's
because it's it's part of Southern
Culture especially at the time it was
kind of there was a paranormal [__]
streak in the South a lot about
paranormal [__] holy crap dude what the
hell is that neighbors the possibility
of the
Paranormal what's the name of that
[__] movie I know it's like I can't
remember it either the bad guy wasn't
Jean Simmons was
he that was another that was the one
with Tom celic I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah I I know that that one but that was
runaway wasn't it yeah runaway I think
it was Runway I think we covered that
one actually Jean Simmons did a good job
as he actually did a good job as a he
did actually you wouldn't think that
he'd be able to act but um you know
other than that [__] runaway was a
[__] shitty movie it all right it
wasn't it wasn't great this was a ripoff
of Robocop right well yeah kind of
Victor says I'm annoying as [__]
y um I'm not he also says I'm liberal
but I got head from a dude wearing a
Maga hat before yeah yeah you never know
what could happen well yeah you never
know what's going to happen and then
Oracle said a guy I know wrote what is
now considered the definitive history of
the chicken ranch horh housee okay uh
inside the Texas Chicken Ranch the
definitive account of the best little wh
house he was able to interview the last
maid uh Madam before she died okay
that's awesome now I might have to read
that holy
crap I I don't know why but it's like I
saw saw that movie when I was a kid cuz
like I said I used we got you know HBO
and Cinemax and all that other kind of
crap when I was a kid uh cuz my dad
worked for the cable companies so we got
it for free and so and my parents didn't
really care what I watched so I watched
just like pretty much everything and
that was one of the ones that I watched
but I hadn't seen it since I was a kid
so when it came up again and we were
doing the whole Bert Reynolds thing like
watching smoking the Bandit and all of
that I was like oh my God we should
totally watch best little the 80s that
would have been that would have been
family friendly in the 80s people don't
realize how hardcore the yeah yeah yeah
yeah 80s movies did not give a single
[__] they did not give a single [__] no
they're like yeah it's a family movie we
got it's about a horror house we got
tits and beheadings and yeah yeah yeah
it's about a horror house but it's yeah
it's all it's very wholesome
yeah it kind of was I mean it was it was
a pretty awesome it's a musical the the
the the horrors that were in there were
portrayed as as good people they were
just trying to make a living and they
you know which had families timeit like
that had families and had problems and
wanted some of them wanted to live
normal lives they didn't want to be
horres anymore saving up their money
moving out remember yeah yeah so like I
said it was kind of ahead of its time in
that way yeah somebody asked me earlier
if I would retell the story about the my
coworker from a long time ago who um
tried to serve everybody [__] really
when did this happen this was a long
time ago I didn't know about this this
was was um probably when was this late
'90s or early
2000s I worked for a new before I knew
you yeah yeah yeah a long time before I
knew you I worked for a newspaper a
weekly newspaper in Daytona Beach and
there was a woman who worked there I'm
even going to say what her name is she's
probably dead by now her name's
Laura and her and her husband were weird
were part of some like they were part of
some kind of like fundamentalist cult or
something I don't it wasn't one that I'd
ever heard of before but it was kind of
it was one of those weird like offshoot
Fundy Cults right so they had like all
these weird rules and
[__] and no one was mean to her or
nothing like that but I mean people did
kind of say like I thought she was kind
of weird cuz she was kind of weird you
know what I mean I don't know what it
was that caused her to do this
particular thing but we had a potluck
for
I don't remember if it was Christmas or
some holiday or some [__] like that
because they were always doing stuff oh
everybody bring food or whatever and she
brought in some cookies and the cookies
had [__] in them how do you know I'm not
really sure how I don't know if somebody
ate one and they were like hey there's
[__] in this or you could just tell
because they smelled like that yeah it
wasn't human [__] I don't think I think
it was well she lived on a farm right so
it was either I think it was pig [__]
huh is I think what it was I don't
remember who it was that told me this
was a long time ago but I don't remember
who it was that told me that they had
discovered it and um we're like yeah
don't eat Lura cookies but we're not
going to say anything about it's like I
don't even know if they yeah I don't
even know if they confronted her about
it but it's just cuz that's uh biohazard
hello like somebody could die from that
y'all are too polite and I'm not really
sure I mean she was trying to poison
people that's what I mean I'm not really
I didn't really find out about it until
like after could be osis in there who
know that's what I mean so it's like
that's not [__] funny like you know
what I mean that's like I said it's a
biohazard so she noticed her cookies
didn't get eaten huh
yeah I mean yeah Tammy said she should
have been fired I think she was a little
while after right well did people make
it do they know it was true I don't know
I'm just saying what I heard I didn't
really I didn't really get in the middle
of it maybe that dude made that up but
I'm just saying I would have gotten down
to the bottom of see if it true yeah
that sounds sounds like some [__] she
would have done though it also sounds
like somebody would have made up she's
weird like that yeah so that absolutely
sounds like something she would have
done
weird I I would have gone [__] is
there pig [__] in
here they're saying there's pig [__] in
this why do these cookies smell like I'm
going to make her eat some yeah it's
like yeah how about you eat some yeah
see this is yall look at me this you
confront a [__]
it's rumored that there's [__] in these
cookies is that true it's not well then
you eat some eat six of them yeah I'm
I'm going to sit right here and watch
sit right here and eat some all then
call the cops call the cops on that
[__] I would have too yeah I mean she's
trying to poison us yeah well and I kind
of feel like because maybe it was the
late 990s or the early 2000s they didn't
really think that much of it yeah yeah
but nowadays if somebody pulled that
crap oh they would absolutely haul you
off in handcuffs yeah you know what I
mean cuz yeah you they would accuse you
of trying to like poison people that
might be attempted murder yeah if you
got the right
lawyer Victor said do You' all remember
the first movie you saw in the theater
mine was labomba oh I remember that one
and uh the line at our Litt Town Theater
wrapped around the block I actually
quite like labomba it's about Richie
bonss you know I grew up they were
taking me to the MAA in theater so I I
don't remember what the I think the
first one the first one I remember
seeing in the theater when I was little
was the cat from outer
space which was one of the liveaction
Disney movies from the 7s yeah I might
have seen that too but I I don't
remember that as well I remember seeing
waterers Shi down as a little kid and
loving it love water [__] that's a great
[__] movie yeah even when the even
when the bunny rabbits were getting
crushed by all the [__] they got
buried into their [__] Burrows by the
construction company that movie upset me
when I was a kid because I was just like
who a Bonnies a little trauma I read the
book too the book is also fantastic good
little British animated
movie it's good they also the same uh
production team also did one called the
plague dogs yeah which I believe is on
tub but it's also
animated and it's always I'm always kind
of like yeah I should probably watch
that and I'm like eh do I really want to
cuz man water Shi down is like
depressing enough but you know what I
mean there an aure story yeah they made
it made new burrow yeah most of them
made it yeah well people get killed yeah
that was a generation from the World War
II generation coming up with that stuff
yeah you know what I mean they knew what
reality was they were getting kids ready
that yeah man you got to do the right
thing bad [__] happens like you you know
just muscle through it you know power
through that
[__]
yeah Victor said water ship down was
scary as [__] I yeah I thought it was
really scary when yeah even even had a
warning about
totalitarianism remember how that one
that one uh burrow was kind of like run
by
Nazis where they they they didn't have
any kind of Freedom yeah then they had
the other burrow where they were all
these ghostly damn rabbits living in
there and they were just didn't have
much life in them and it turned out that
they were being fed every day in the
burrow but they were also being
snared remember that they were they were
in a farm yeah and the farmer was eating
them regularly but feeding them to keep
them there and there was there's a
warning about [__] easy handouts yeah
they had exchanged [__] freedom for
easy
handout and they were death always
loomed over them murder Hornet said I
refuse to watch Cannibal Holocaust
because they killed real animals yeah I
don't blame you yeah I got I got five
minutes into it I said I turn that [__]
off when that dude stuck that stick
through that little bitty quad Mundy and
[__] [__] it's going no no no no no
I'm going no no no no yeah I mean I
can't even watch fake violence against
animals in movies kill all the people
you want I don't give a [__] like as
long as it's fake obviously but do [__]
to animals and movies even if it's fake
no thanks no yeah they're doing that
[__] to the animals just to make a movie
right you know what I mean no man if
you're going to eat the animal cut its
head off [__] kill it fast you're
sitting there sticking a blunt not even
a sharp stick really sticking it through
a little Kat when he guy had it in his
hand he's petting it one minute then he
stuck I said no this this shit's not
cool I'd [__] snap that dude's neck
for doing that it's very [__] up
[__] uh very [__] up no you know
and I killed a lot of animals but I was
eating them and I shot them and it's
instant death pretty much they don't
know what happened and and it's prey
animals a quite a Mooney is not a
[__] prey animal that's not something
that is for food that's just something
that crimes around the tree you
know no meat there man so it died for
nothing
yeah talking about ' 80s movies Allison
said the ending of Sleepaway C up in the
80s damn yeah um like I said 80s movies
turn out it was a guy right yeah he was
a boy like yeah spoiler alert well no um
you know 80s movies didn't didn't really
[__] around they didn't really [__]
around I remember seeing that and I was
like man that was a dude she was cute
well I mean the actor was a girl yeah it
turned out it wasn't a dude but it was a
female they faked
it well for the movie they did they
faked it for the movie but I mean yeah
the character was supposed to be oh my
God it was a boy the whole time yeah
which like I said but that I mean that
last scene is like iconic of them like
scrolling down but that was a female
actor yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
actually made I was confused I thought
maybe it was no no no that was that that
was actually a girl but
um they actually made a sequel to that
which I don't I think I saw it but I
don't really remember that much about it
I don't even know if we've ever done
sleep away camp have we ever reviewed
sleep away camp maybe we should all
right I got to go to the bathroom we got
a lot of people in here for uh Friday
too bad I got let's see what everybody's
talking
about when I get back I might need
another one another one yeah you don't
have to drive right yeah I don't it's
8:20 she's looking hot as [__] she goes
in there man she looks like fing she put
elvir to shame way she's looking right
now she's been yeah she's up there
giggling working out on all that
gear all right Zach said uh Hey guys
good news just did my first solo
directing gig the other night directed a
friend's music
video what kind of music video was
it
yeah Victor he he Victor he he knows
water ship down it was scary as [__] it
was scary when you're a kid me and Jen
watched it recently I think you could
see it for free on YouTube
actually I just wanted to see if my
memory of it held up because I was a
little kid I saw it in the theater I
don't remember what year it was it must
have been five or six when I saw it uh
somebody could check real quick see what
year that came out I saw it the year it
came out I might have been
seven
um yeah it has some scary scenes in it
uh but I I Remember Loving the movie
well we saw it again man and it held up
it it's it's a it's a good story the
animation in it is good and uh yeah it
had some dramatic scenes in it and it
had a lot of uh morality lessons in it
for life I recommend that movie I think
all kids should watch that movie
waterers ship town was [__] awesome
you adults love it too it's a good book
too you should also read good movie The
Book is very
good Oscar says Jenny 78 so okay so I
was
nine not Oscar says jny logic kill the
kids save the animals well I will admit
that I do like animals better than kids
so so it is kind of
logical well like I said it's just kind
of like I don't know I don't know I know
that's kind of messed up
but that's just the way I feel about it
sorry I'm not really and actually if a
horror movie has the balls to like Kill
a Kid in there I'm just like all right
fair play but the second they start
messing with like kitties or dog or
something like I don't even I I don't
like what you're doing nope I
don't Zach said I think the first movie
I saw in the theater is one of the
Rugrats movies back in 2001 when I was
four wow you're so young yeah like I
said I'm pretty sure the first movie I
remember
seeing was the cat from outer space I
don't remember what year that came
out that was one of the live action
Disney movies I don't even remember what
happened in it other than the cat coming
here in like a flying saucer or
something but I remember we were in the
first row and I think it was me and my
cousin and like our parents and stuff
but that's pretty much all I remember
about
it
um Danny said first movie I saw in
theaters was Milo and Otis oh yeah I
remember that one that's a good movie
actually um Oracle said Jenny did you
hear there's a new tea king fisher
coming out in February oh [__] I'm going
to have to read that I for some reason I
was just kind of like I really need to I
wanted to do another book review but I
still
haven't I feel bad because I still
haven't managed to get through slooh
foot
yet and I keep doing because I don't
have it in ebook I have it in print and
so I just I don't know I just haven't
got around to reading it so it's like I
keep going to my Kindle unlimited and
being like well maybe I can find like an
ebook I can read real quick and I
started reading one today that's called
the neighbor but I can't remember what
what's the name of the author I can't
remember what her name is but it's kind
of like a thriller but it's supernatural
you know what I mean like it's I don't
know if it's possession I I don't know
what's going on yet cuz I'm only about
halfway through it but it's actually
like really good it's like pretty page
turning but so I might do a review of
that next week sometime um but yeah so
I'm enjoying it so far and as long as it
doesn't piss me off like toward the end
we'll see how that goes cuz you guys
know if you watch my review of um hidden
pictures you'll know how something
starts out kind of good and then I'm
like what where are we going with this
oh we're going here okay you know what I
mean that kind of [__] so I'm hoping
that this
will go in a good
direction Oscar said Jenny how about a
night shift by Stephen King book review
oh that's actually a good idea because
I've read that book like a [__] ton of
times what's up Oscar I didn't know you
were here bro yeah he just got here like
not too long ago it looks
like but um yeah that was that's
actually I I really like a lot of
Stephen King's novels but I think he's a
really good short story writer you know
like more than maybe people give him
credit for and he's written a [__] ton
of short stories and I'm really into
those and night shift I think is
probably my favorite Skeleton Crew is
good too but I think night shift um all
of my favorite short stories of his are
in that book Skeleton Crew no night
shift night shift uhhuh I had skeleton
crew that was a good a lot of good [__]
I in it yeah I have that one too
Survivor type oh that's that's a great
story yeah that's a great story I love
they made like an animated uh adaptation
of that for the new creep show that's on
shudder then they actually did a really
good job because that would kind of be
hard to do like as a live action had to
take some of those antihist my nose
started getting plugged up again I'm
actually yeah like when I did the live
stream yesterday I was kind of didn't
feel all that great but um I feel better
now I was waking up hacking last night
but I feel kind of like better now so it
might be that alcohol I'm not really
sure yeah I might it keep it from
coughing yeah that's what I'm thinking
might need another drink while uh no
we're gonna have to leave in uh what no
we got an hour still got an hour okay so
we got to leave around 9:30 don't we
yeah yeah it doesn't open till 10: we're
we're fine we got plenty of time plenty
of time and like I said I'm ready okay
like I can just grab my purse and my
phone and yeah we can
go make sure my news you guys are just
new to the show Jenny's looking
fantastic uh I grabbed the camera did a
[__] did a whole [__] pan on this
girl look at man this outfit Jen show
them again one time for the new people
that have come look at this outfit I
don't have to get up do I yeah go ahead
and get up goad get now I have to get
yeah yeah look at how cute this outfit
is yeah all
right
ridiculous yeah you're ridiculous yeah
walk walk around walk around walk around
walk
around yeah thought going to get me look
how good she looks how you going to get
me another drink I'll get you another
drink okay all
right you're a silly you're so silly
hold let me put let me put the camera
back yeah put the camera put the I'm put
the camera back oh for put the camera I
put the camera
back Shameless promotions you are
Shameless Shameless promotions do you
see do you see what I have to put up
with it's all funny games do you see
what I have to put that's all funny
games all right make another
drink yeah Tammy said are we gonna get
the same show from Tom yeah don't tempt
him oh yeah yeah I was just did that I
just did that [__] what are you talking
about let's see your ass cracked I just
did that [__] just did that [__] yeah
like I said he's like oh yeah absolutely
I did that [__] as the [__] what you
think what you think I'm [__]
scared I ain't
scared
oh I should show I should show you the
little comic strip that Victor sent me
earlier today about about pegging what
Victor Victor sending you comic strips
about pegging yeah it's trying to get it
into your mind no no it was it was funny
though it was funny all right I'll send
it to you later make another drink was
pretty
funny yeah like I said Tammy it's like
don't he has no shame at all so like
don't and especially if you dare him to
do it then he'll really do it you know
what I
[Laughter]
mean like I said he should have like
pulled the underwear down like for the
ass crack but you know what I mean
that's that's okay that's
okay side stream said um oh wait six
sorry I can't read 60s Ram says uh first
movie I remember seeing was earthquake o
that's a good one I think it was the
sensor around I remember the yeah in
since around I remember that commercial
for that it was early 1975 yeah I was
like 3 years old when that came out I
saw it like a little bit later when it
was on cable I love all those 70s
disaster movies those are so [__]
great I love all those like 70s disaster
movies um and all the' 70s nature runam
muck movies like the big [__] big
killer rats and orca and all that kind
of [__] I love that [__] I think I did a
video over on my scar Salon channel did
I do a video on this I think I did like
a double feature about food of the Gods
and Empire of the ants and um cuz man I
used to love those movies growing up I
had forgotten though when I re-watched
food of the Gods I had forgotten how
much um apparent like real violence
against the rats there was cuz I guess
they shooting the rats with [__] yeah
so it's like I guess they didn't have
those laws back when that movie came out
cuz I was like I watched it again I was
like godamn and I think they drowned
some of the rats too it looked like
That's like
[__] Alison said too much information
oh my God this whole show should be
called too much information the show
what where too much information
about murder Hornet said Jen what's
that what does that say tattoo on your
left shoulder yeah I guess it says that
I can't see cuz that little heart icon
is what's that on your left shoulder
wait which um what's my left oh this one
oh it's um it's Anubis
I've had that a long
time IR says oh my goodness Tom what's
what
say your little your tight little booty
oh is that what it is oh Tom's undies
Tom's undies yeah yeah he's got a whole
bunch of those yeah what do they called
jockmail
yeah that's gay underwear he loves all
the gay the gator wear that's G Gund
wear I'm not really sure what you would
call it well I mean obviously
they have like a bunch of different
they're actually really good quality
they're kind of expensive but they're
really nice yeah quality I do a whole
review you should you should do like a
whole jock mail cuz You' got like a
whole bunch of pairs of them yeah I got
about nine of them now yeah they're nice
all different colors yeah and they and
they definitely like are targeting a gay
audience yeah like with some of well
some of the pairs are just like regular
like gener like the ones he's got
like but yeah they have some that are
like way they got some that are just
kind of like have rainbows on them and
have like stuff about how the with
little things on seual [__] yeah yeah
with little things on it saying it's
like let's make sure warning signs
underwear is covered with lube and other
fluids male fluids [__] like that so as
I was looking at that I was just kind of
like oh wow okay they're going there
some of them are like uh you know in in
the rainbow colors and gay theme stuff
and a lot of jock straps and gay jock
straps and uh asess yeah well it's a
jockstrap and it's got in Rainbow
pattern I got one of them it's in black
and red I got a black and red he has an
asess one it's not asess it's a jack
strap well it's a jack strap it's a jack
which is asess asess ones no the asess
ones are pair just like this it's just
there's a door in the back oh okay oh I
got you there's a door in the back yeah
in the front and a
back Jam would love that [__] J would
just see that [__] go that's so hot
[__] should have never said
anything yeah what fun would that be
yeah
okay we all like easy access we're like
oh look at that there's no access back
there you talking
about one day one day Tom I'm just
teasing I would never do anything
against your well you know that probably
girls in their
[Laughter]
fantasies yeah yeah jockstrap man I
[__] I'll throw that [__] out [__]
tight as [__] it looks good man it looks
like something off a [__] black widow
spider mhm
yeah yeah they're Co that
[__] shakes his little booty around yeah
I streamed in that yeah that's right you
did didn't
you
yeah boots and
[__] murder Hornet said Tom told me if I
paid $800 he would get pegged yeah $800
yeah he's lying now that's nowhere near
the amount of money it would take to
take my
Virgin yeah you said it would take at
least motorc motorcycle money man we're
talking about you have to get me one of
those new [__] sportser asses we were
talking about this the other day though
because you were talking not so much
getting pegged but you were talking
about that Saudi oil cheeks yeah well
you were talking about that girl what's
her what's her name that that girl that
you watch that escort that you watch is
that that a was talking about I think it
might have been a that was talking about
about that no no no that wasn't a girl
talking about that what you talking
about it was a
dude uh it was a dude off a legion of
men Legion of men sounds a little that
sounds a little
threatening it's the man Legion here
they come um he had some uh female
listeners that contacted him and told
him a bunch of stories that happened to
them and they had the proof you he he
she showed him the
proof this girl she was about 22 23
lived out in the middle of nowhere she
was [__] gorgeous she was like a
nine and she was taking photos of
herself and she had an Instagram channel
so she was like an Instagram girl IG
girl and out of the blue a verified
account contacted
her and it was a a [__] son of a
[__] Saudi oil billionaire
mhm and it was a company that he had
owned and it was a representative of the
company first asking her if if she
wanted
to to go on a party on a birthday party
for this famous guy she showed him
pictures of them and that
um would be a week long him and his
guests and uh they would go to Europe
and go to uh Dubai and
all these [__] places and uh all
expenses
paid and uh they would give her
$250,000 and she didn't think it was
true but it turned out it was true they
even [__] gave her a down payment on
it so she said yeah she
went and it was her and [__] like 19
20 other girls and this guy the only
rules were to not take pictures of him
not to post where you were or anything
that you were with him or you couldn't
you could post where you were but you
couldn't post pictures with him
right and she said it was her and
[__] 20
other bachelorettes basically fighting
over this [__]
Saudi oil chic's
son it's like a [__]
billionaire and she said he was nice he
was evidently a good good-look guy too
he like his
30s and every night it was like
orgies
between the dude and all these girls and
the girls on the girls and uh they were
all vying for this guy's attention and
uh evidently he seemed to be
available she ended up leaving the
situation though because around the guy
ended up being a core of like four or
five real hardcore fans that were around
him all the time and they were talking
[__] all the time and I think she went a
couple times if I remember correctly but
what made her stop [__] seeing this
going to on these things was that her
birthday came up and he didn't even know
about it so she's like he doesn't care
about me that kind of [__] of course he
didn't care about and and the reason why
he hired all of y'all to be there yeah
and the reason why you weren't allowed
to take pictures of him because that
[__] was married probably probably yeah
imagine and you know he's got a [__]
Harum for the [__] week you know for
his
birthday but see we were discussing this
because I was like no on one second uh
oh the moral of his story was saying
that times have really
changed in because dudes like this and c
and and celebrities people who have
these verified accounts have access to
all these women that normally they would
never even see or be able to contact out
in the middle of nowhere yeah she live
in [__] Kansas she lived like [__]
nowhere and this dude got a hold of her
and was throwing her in the middle of
these [__] ories and she's every time
she [__] goes home she's got another
$250,000 in her account he's topping her
account
up she doesn't realize she's a hooker
but that's what that's what this is you
know what I mean well yeah and uh
technically yeah so Jen's like well [__]
250,000 I'd have to go and I said I'm
like and Tom's like you better go you
better go I'll be packing
you packing your bags2 for $250 [__]
th000 you better go I'll be packing your
bags you better suck all the dicks that
[__] come your way for a week of work
[__] that'll solve a lot of [__]
problems yeah I wouldn't love it I mean
I don't mind I wouldn't mind like um you
know kind of getting with the other
chicks that would be that would be fine
but it's just kind of like I don't like
having to like [__] some random dude but
I would do it for a week for $250,000 I
mean if you said it was okay so so Jen
comes at me she say what about you what
if he wanted you and I said I'd have to
see him first but if he was all right
I'm you going to be packing my bag cuz
I'm going have to get my [__]
cocksuck I had on $250,000 that's a
[__] lot of money that's what I mean
you I I was like I could live for
decades on
$250,000 I'll do a lot for $250,000 I
mean seriously there's some [__] I won't
do for any amount of money what the [__]
man but 2250 [__] mean I'm thinking
trying to think [__] like yeah you
better do it too if they if they ask you
going happen though what I'm just well
yeah I was like nobody wants my old
badass but I'm just saying if it if that
happened yeah um you know those dudes
that are offering that kind of [__] they
always fall on people in their
20s yeah yeah they're looking for those
I don't think we're ever going to get
into a situation we passed that [__]
what was that movie uh that had Dem
Moore in it Indecent Proposal yeah yeah
it was Demi Moore and Woody harelson
right and they were married and wasn't
it was it Robert
Redford what did this m this movie was
like from the 90s and like look at all
this money I'm making for thank you
Jeffy Jeff have you guys ever created an
episode about unsolved cases in Canada
it astounded me on how many recent
unsolved murders in Canada there are I
think the only one we've done about
Canada we did one about London Ontario
AKA murder City uh cuz there was a lot
of murders that happened there but that
was like 60s and 70s but I've been
noticing that too because I've been
writing stuff about um you know unsolved
murders for my crime in Memorial blog
and I've been going through like all the
Canadian stuff and there are like a lot
of unsold well there's a lot of unsolved
murders everywhere sadly but um yeah
there are a lot in Canada Jeff R says
Tom would be a hit at the Eagle Wilton
Manners I don't know what that is oh
well I guess we'll find
out well that's probably what it is yeah
but yeah so I was thinking because I
remember when that movie Indecent
Proposal came out that was kind of like
the the question of the day among
couples was hey if Robert Redford or the
Robert Redford equivalent like came to
you and said hey I'll give you a million
dollars like to sleep with your wife I'm
like I think most people would probably
and like in the movie they did it
spoiler alert but then it was just kind
of like everything went wrong afterward
but I was just kind of like I don't know
for a million
dollars it was just and especially if it
was just one night it's just you didn't
just have to put up with it High Desert
said all those oil shakes are wh man
[__] yeah yeah but they got the money
to be a mad [__] like I said it doesn't
sound like a well I was going to say it
doesn't some it doesn't sound like a lot
of fun some of it sounds like a lot of
fun like you get to travel and be on a
yacht and like have all the best of
everything that'd be awesome but it's
like having to have sex with random
people that's doesn't sound too much fun
but like I said for a quarter of a
million dollars I would probably endure
it for it was just that dude and random
[__] hot
chicks that you were hanging out with
yeah and most of the time they were you
most of the time you would just be
hanging out yeah you know what I mean it
wouldn't be 24/7 orgies for a week just
everyone we get tired yeah so mostly
hanging out like I said I'd put up with
a lot for a quarter of a million dollar
qu million dollars yeah CU that would
cuz like I said I could live on that for
trying to get invited back
yeah hey man there's a price for
everything that that in decent proposal
ship yeah yeah that movie yeah there's a
price for everything there is well like
I said you got to be honest yeah well
and I think that's what fascinated
people about that movie because it's
like you know do I I want to sleep with
some random dude no but it's like if
some dude came and said hey I'll give
you a million dollars like for one night
and like you knew about it and you KN
like I'd be like that's a million
dollars yeah that's a million [__]
that's a million [__] dollars we'd be
set for life yeah yeah just for that as
long as as long as a dude wouldn't stalk
me after that or nothing like that as
long as I don't have to [__] look at
his face or call him again or nothing
like that yeah you know if it would just
be over then you could just forget I
would even get
jealous yeah well like I said I just
want to make sure you you you were safe
yeah you got to make sure he's not a
[__] cial because you never know you
never know right and I'd be like I want
half the money up front yeah cuz I want
to make sure you're not [__] down
payment that's what they did to that
girl that's what I mean she wasn't sure
it give me a half a million up front and
then we'll do it and then give me the
other yeah when when they sent her
[__] like $60,000 she's like okay
yeah I'll be there yeah okay so I guess
yeah cuz they gave her a down payment
yeah because anybody she wanted clothes
[__] oh and here's another thing and I
just this just occurred to me so any of
y'all that are still on Facebook have
any of y'all ladies been suddenly
getting messages from dudes offering to
be your sugar daddy yeah because I've
had two of those in the last few weeks
the first guy offered how much did the
first guy offer uh $1,000 a week yeah I
think it was ,000 and then the second
guy offered $3,000 a week yeah it's a
robot I think yeah it's not I don't
think it's a real person no but I was
like is this some new scam that's going
around I've never had these before like
yeah I'd always have like random dick
pics and [__] like that but it's like
this is new I would think that it's a uh
a robo
pimp it's an AI program looking for
girls that will sell and then it puts
them in a database and hooks them up
with clients that's what I think it is I
think it's a Rob yeah that that makes a
lot of sense to me yeah because I the
first time that hookers I've been I've
been hit by Rob Robo hookers but you can
see them coming a mile away yeah I'm
sitting here on [__] Instagram or or
[__] X and I'm getting [__] hit on
by a girl who's a nine out of the blue
no that's a [__] that doesn't happen
in real life it doesn't happen in real
life doesn't happen online okay it does
not happen
online so it's a it's a robo hooker it's
not a hooker though it's probably
something like somebody trying to get
your credit card in information or
trying to get you to go onto a dating
site or some stupid [__] like that yeah
it's just like sales but it's just
interesting because like the first time
it happened I was like I just thought it
was kind of funny and I was like hey Tom
look somebody wants to be my sugar daddy
like what it you know what I mean I
didn't think it was a real person and he
was like looking at the thing he's like
oh my God that's so weird and then like
a few days ago I got another one like
from a different account yeah and I was
just kind of like this must be some new
scam they're running running it on women
now I did get hit by a couple of Robo
real Robo hookers but that was like two
200 17 that's when we were living in
Sanford and it
was it came over
messenger
through Facebook that's what these were
yeah go through Facebook yeah there were
Facebook messages and it and it would be
I'm here come meet me and it would [__]
who were you and it would and yeah and
it was in local areas right and it would
show the girl and everything it show
where the the location was and it was
suspicious locations you know bars and
restaurants and it would it showed the
girl and but those only went on for like
a couple
weeks you get one every few days yeah
like a couple weeks I think uh Facebook
cracked down on it was some kind of
robot that was doing it yeah but it was
showing you where girls that were
selling were yeah yeah and in your local
area you know give a sh me Sanford
right restaurants that I knew of but
never went
to so have my
geolocations you know what I mean right
it was just in my
area yeah see that's what I mean so I
kind of feel like this new thing like
offering to be a sugar daddy is that's
maybe the female equivalent of that yeah
like female being on the end of it
they're like you said maybe they're
trying to like recruit people into
Jeffy Jeffy says the Eagle's a leather
bar where he works yeah I go down there
I'll dominate in a leather bar yeah oh
my God they would love you oh yeah yeah
I put on a [__] show and everything I
ain't bashful he's really not I put on a
show man he'll strip down to his underwe
well [__] he'll probably strip down to
nothing yeah they if they're paying just
boots yeah if they're he'll just like
they're paying swing his [__] around if
they're paying if they're paying and
they're being cool and respectful I'll
dance for them I'm going to dance
tonight going to dance at the club
tonight now your [__] hanging out but
you know well may well maybe no I ain't
going know probably not no me [__] I'll
be dancing [__] Toby dancing with me
we got got a [__] on
video posted that [__] before on on
Instagram but no you know I'm
not I'm not you know if I'm having fun
I'm having fun yeah it's all good yeah
I'm not [__] up I don't get [__]
he's not shy I'm not don't get scared
he's not shy what are those dude's
goingon to do to me man [__] I can
fight
you know I'm not I'm not shy in certain
they can't make me do anything I don't
want to do I'm not shy in certain
environments but I know to be cautious
in other environments you know what I
mean I'm a I'm a I'm a girl so we have
to be like more circumspect about what I
already told my story [__] I was
[__] goth dude in my 20s [__]
dressed up like [__] lat trying to
get into the goth club it was [__]
closed this is over in [__] uh Rhode
Island it was
uh so I asked fing one of one of the
bouncers that says where go I can't
really go to any of these other [__]
clubs the way I'm [__] where's a safe
place for a goth to go I said it to [__]
one of the goth people by oh go in there
there was the [__] old go to the gay
bar old gay bar and it was yeah that's
always safe and it was a gay bar filled
with old queens yeah it was all fancy
you'll be you'll be all right in there
yeah old fancy bar that's where I would
go too I would feel a lot more
comfortable they're all in their [__]
50s and 60s and [__] with [__]
life-size Tom Cruz posters and [__] and
Marlin Brando and everything Tom and
they're playing good music they're
playing good music in there that's what
I mean they got some [__] taste at
least yeah and uh everybody was all the
old guys [__] were like would you
like to sit down I'll by says you don't
understand I'm straight right but I will
have a drink with you oh no no it's okay
it's okay say you know they they were
fascinated why are you dressed like you
know you're you're a goth aren't you you
[__] like that oh yeah just talking with
these old guys that were [__]
flirting and buying me [__] drinks I
think I got five
drinks excellent and I was just like all
right guys [__] nice meeting you and
Sh shake them and [__] you know just
just they're just people just people you
know yeah they [__] make you the
center of attention and [__] like I said
any but it's okay you know what I mean
likeing and not going to hurt you any
City you go to if there aren't any goth
bars go to the gay bars yeah yeah if
you're goed out you go to a gay bar
[__] I mean I've done that well when
you were young cute I was but you know
I've done that a lot of people do that
yeah like I said there's a lot of
crossover MH you got to go to the safe
space I'm not going to some [__]
regular ass bar or sports bar or nothing
like that I'm get my ass beat so well
gentlemen I have to go or gang raped my
club is open I got to go to oh he's
leaving oh he's
going a it's nice meeting you guys you
know hug at everybody okay I'll see you
guys around like oh he's leaving you
know just way it is Hi Desert said what
kind of music do you like to dance to
uh I like [__] all kinds of music
really as long as it's good well I like
80s
music some of the'80s pop music was good
uh goth music some of the Industrial
Music um yeah I like goth got have a
good beat I like Post Punk yeah Post
Punk KFDM some industrial um older
industrial yeah nitb I really like if
they bringing on nitb I'm going to be
out there I mean I can't not dance to
that
suie
um what else oh I'm gonna dance to the
[__] uh to uh to uh [__]
Psychedelic Furs yeah that too yeah um
Swiss blade Symphony old goth
Bam um I even like some of the uh
[__] uh Neo folk like uh yeah yeah
Death in June current 93 oh my God I
love current
93 um I I liked [__] um what was the
name of that tear Garden yeah that was
really good skinny puppy well tear
Garden same singer as legendary pink
dots yeah yeah yeah yeah legary pink
dots because I also love legendary pink
dots yeah Zach says uh I still say if
you guys ever come to Indiana we three
need to hang out at Greg's the gay bar I
like to go to I think Tom would love
Club oh yeah we absolutely will yeah
yeah I like gay bars I got to bring a
woman with me you know for [__]
cover cuz the [__] might get
out of control never know but but no you
know [__] well we we a lot of gay a lot
of gays come to the clubs that we hang
out at you know like I said there's a
lot of crossover lot of crossover
there's a lot of crossover because
particularly the place we're going
tonight which is Barbarella it's
momentto Mor which is the goth night but
it's kind of like the fact that it's in
a warehouse District it's not like
nobody can just wander in unless you
know where it is and [__] like that so
people everybody feels safe going there
so people come there like however you
know what I mean it's it's actually very
scandy CL it's really and no one's going
to [__] with you like no one will [__]
with you for any reason yeah um which is
really nice there've been women in there
they wearing nexts or nothing there've
been [__] muscle dudes in there with
nothing but leather straps and [__] and
horns on remember that guy guy all right
yeah that was one of the baby bats he
must couldn't have been about 25 26 yeah
that was just like a couple weeks and he
was just his big [__] beefy
[__] in there and he was
straight though he he was he had a lot
of girls you know so you can't judge him
by what they're wearing you might see a
dude you think he's straight As Arrow
he's gay you might see a dude might see
a dude you think all that motherfucker's
gay no he's straight you can't tell in
the goth seed you got to know you got to
know it doesn't matter with us really we
don't really care no one asks we just
care who you are yeah we don't really
care about your orientation we just care
about who you
are bad dwell said wow they look great
thank you like you are about to go
clubbing yes we are we're going to
momentto Mor uh later on in probably
about half an hour we got to go yeah uh
he said I miss little m is there what's
up little mov you missed it man I was
stripping well hey yeah you missed it I
to do it again yeah might have to do it
again oh [__] she's going to try to get
me [__] never
mind she says here's some drinking money
thank you so much also Jenny your hair
is badass thank you very much these are
some of my favorite hair Falls I need to
get some more of these actually some of
this is real hair but some of it is fake
hair what are are you showing your hair
doing oh okay showing your hair uhhuh
sure a likely story and showing your
hair story don't get that look how hot
Jenny's looking look at his boots look
at me like sitting all [__] [__] up
you're not sitting [__] up I'm kind of
let me go to the restroom hold on one
second um bad dwell also says skinny
puppy yeah we love that yeah I love
skinny pupp I we saw them live not too
long ago this a couple years when yeah
he said anybody remember throbbing
gristle yeah I actually really like
throbbing gristle they are hard to dance
studio I will admit but I really do like
throbbing gristle uh murder Hornet said
Ministry yeah I like some of ministry
stuff too
um Zach says plus if yall come with me I
can hide behind Tom if we run it into my
ex oh my God that'll be super
fun uh murder Hornet said can I go to
the Goss bar with tennis shoes on uh you
can but um people might no one is going
to do anything to you but people might
like give you [__] looks all night so
if you can put up with that then you'll
probably be fine you know what I mean I
will note that some people if they plan
to dance a lot like most of the guys
wear the boots you know what I mean the
Stompy boots um but some people do wear
comfortable shoes because they know
they're going to be dancing a lot so
there is that although I kind of feel
like that's more that's kind of more as
Barbarella does momento Mory on Friday
nights which is the goth industrial
night Saturday nights they do 80s New
Wave which is actually my favorite I
love that [__] [__] and um all the
regulars there are like really cool so
some people there are like pretty
dressed down because they're like man
I'm going to dance all [__] night so
I'm just wearing like not tennis shoes
necessarily but just like comfortable
shoes you know what I mean so they won't
wear anything like super
elaborate because they know that they're
going to have to like dance around all
night cuz some of these clothes are a
little bit restrictive this isn't too
bad the only the restrictive thing I
have on tonight is these [__] nails
like I said this is going to be like a
problem
Oh I thought you were going to like do
some [__] there yeah that's
[Music]
right that's right thrust it thrust it
at the camera time thrust it there you
go there you go that's what I was
waiting
[Laughter]
for oh my God
Tom little movie said I missed the
stripping but I didn't miss that episode
with Tom Speedo h
oh you saw the episode of okay all right
I'm I'm gon give her a [__] oh here we
go here we go here it goes again this is
like the third
times every time like new people come in
he's like oh I have to show my underwear
[Laughter]
again oh my God like I said and look
it's like right there it's like right
there [__]
[__] you're hilarious H who you want to
see the backat
yeah let's see your let's see your cute
butt you have a cute butt that's right
work it [__] money it is this is worth
[__] money
[Laughter]
[__] we're the
worst pretty
much let me go make another drink
actually no I don't want to make another
drink I got to drive well you got half
an hour so it's up to you it's you got
half an hour before we have to leave no
I need to settle down you sure yeah I'm
just going to get U some passion fruit
drink okay I'm not going to put the
alcohol in
it look pook is on camera you're on
camera PUK she's like I don't care if
I'm on camera or not what are you guys
why are you guys not paying attention to
me bad don't well said I wish I had a
good
pulch Tom is so proud of that vul
seriously oh
[__]
uh Zach also says I'd say come see the
drag show there too but the base from
the sound system can liquefy your organs
I swear I've been an IMax IMax is that
weren't that
loud we should if we ever get to Indiana
one day we totally should but you should
you should come down here too you should
come and hang out with us that would be
fun that would be fun we should I'm
going go ahead and plug little mover's
uh Channel little mover's uh Fitness
chick she does uh I think what else is
it you do little movie I think you did
some like
uh what's up poop hold on what up I got
your
bite got your bite I think she's got
some uh podcasting that she does also
but um she's got a Instagram and she's
just a little uh little cute ebony pixie
who fing works out skinny she's probably
maybe I don't know five feet tall she
probably weighs about
95 lbs and it's all
muscle she's looking good doing Fitness
and
[__] man I feel like a gigantic
Frankenstein monster next to somebody
she's it yeah yeah she's itty
bitty I'm not that tall I'm just
um what's the word solid that's it yeah
Jen's picked up a couple pounds of
muscle lately well yeah yeah her
training she's comeing along real
good been working out been taking been
taking the been taking the hormones yeah
yeah she's uh she's not Natty she she's
done stuff she's done all the ones women
should do and some of the ones that
women shouldn't do she done it um with
to great effect what funny she responded
very well to 19 North testosterone
nandrolone
Deca [__] little bit of deca [__]
went a long way on that M girl but the
thing about it is that nothing else
really did yeah the stuff that we tried
before that didn't really do
anything everybody's different this was
the first thing that actually like had a
noticeable effect oh
yeah a month later you could you could
just her shape the physicality just
[__] went through well I lost a bunch
of weight yeah a lot of fat and then
lost a lot of fat gain muscle yeah it
was crazy yeah
so said get her on the anavar Tom wa we
did say I'm a bad man you are you didn't
know Zach come on
man we did anavar didn't we yeah anavar
anavar week it didn't really do anything
like I said the only thing that's done
anything was the stuff that I'm on now
yeah prior to that like nothing really
had an effect but when we started doing
this um it immediately like i' lost a
bunch of weight and like yeah muscle
started building up and all this other
stuff so yeah Oscar said you guys are
aging in Reverse I'm trying
to
um part of it is diet and
exercise oh uh yeah Ian says on anavar
yeah she's done anavar that really
wasn't effective everybody Ian's also
he's a
Gyra
um anavar is often faked people don't
people don't realize how expensive real
anavar is I mean it's like $20,000 for a
pound of it so a lot of anavar that's
out there on the market may not actually
be anavar it might be something else it
might be
winra it didn't she's done winw too went
the pills it didn't really make that
much difference it didn't really like
nothing really did much of anything the
only thing I noticed that made the
difference on her was uh Deca [__]
that was real instant yeah that happened
like almost immediately one time I got
her some some um Prima bowling Prima
bowling seemed to work but primabol is
very expensive DEA is a lot more bang
for the buck you just give her less of
that
um so you know you can get a bottle of
milligram decad Dura Ballin which is G
given to women people say you can't give
that to women yes you can that's one the
reason why they made made it you can
give it to a woman uh they give it to
women for certain wasting diseases I
mean nothing weird happened to me yet
yeah uh women that [__] come down
with HIV they'll give them they'll give
them that keep them from wasting
away um just everybody is slightly
different I'm not a doctor I'm not going
to tell you what to take I'm not going
to tell you how much to take
but a lot of people well the medical
industry and doctors will say that 50
milligrams a week is a safe dose it
won't do much in terms of v valorization
in other words making masculine features
gym girls will take 100 milligrams some
of 200 300 for limited amounts of
time have a big impact but you can't do
it for very long you have to come back
to a smaller
dose
um you can't take a lot of anything
forever unless you're a guy guys can
take a lot of that [__] for a long time
you don't have to worry about the
masculinization because we're expected
to look masculine when a woman it's
going to change the way they sound way
they look Jen's voice has deepened a
little bit mhm but it's technically it's
not permanent back off of her in a year
from now it would kind of go back
similar to what it
was but she's still within the female
range it's a little
grally but a lot of women have
that a lot of people don't realize that
Jen is over 50 okay she's an older woman
and you can do a lot with an older woman
because you're not fighting her normal
uh endrin system she's
postmenopausal so you're not fighting a
normal andrien
system now what they give teenage girls
for for um birth control is basically
like 75 milligrams of of [__] Deca is
basically what it is mixed with estrogen
that's kind of what they're giving them
and they're living their whole lives
like that I wouldn't recommend it I do
not believe in hormonal birth control
for women it it's it's mind altering and
it it changes what a young woman prefers
it'll make them like real beta
males it'll make them asexual and not
have much of drives and not much Lust
For Life it's better to let a woman have
normal when she's young to keep those
hormones normal just have a period [__]
it don't get pregnant use a
condom when you get older it's different
you know after you've had your kids when
your hormonal systems start shutting
down and you're no real you're not
really look you're not going to be
fertile you can start messing around
with hormones but you don't do that to a
young person what I'm doing I would
never done it as a young guy I'm doing
it as an older guy I had very low went
to the doctor had very low testosterone
by the time I was [__] in my late 40s
and I I legally got HRT and then I
started realizing yeah this is good I
want more and I started bolstering and
educating myself and doing stuff and I
got a lot of gas in my tank I can live a
long time doing what I'm doing because
I'm not doing that
much um I want to look like I look now
at 70 and there are dudes that have done
it and they did it with less knowledge
and less technology that I had cuz they
were my for runners but there are guys
that have lived 70s 90 90
s Jack Lane lived in
96 he was doing test in probably
anavar well [__] today he would have
been doing some other stuff that would
have helped him even
more so the the technology is getting
better I will say though that I was on
birth control pills for a long time like
in my 20s and 30s and it didn't have any
averse side effects really it was just
after like I was on them for a long time
didn't have anything bad happen didn't
get pregnant either um and then I went
off them for a little while and then I
went back on them probably like in my
late 30s or early 40s and then like it
started to affect me a little bit more
but it might have been like a different
formulation I'm not really sure um let's
see High Desert says you don't look
older than 35 Jen wow oh thank you I'm
actually
51 years old born in 19
72 yeah um Oscar said we don't have a
goian in El Paso unfortunately that is
very sad I mean I'm sure there's
probably a couple hanging around but and
then Oscar also says Tom Define as a
young guy probably what like in their in
your 20s you probably yeah but it also
depends on the situation you can go have
your blood work done see what your
testosterone levels are if you're in
your
20s I would not have done this knowing
what I know now I probably would have
gotten involved in this in my mid-30s 32
33 I probably would have started juicing
a little bit you to do a lot you know
it's all dose dependent just small
amount probably would have helped me out
yeah because you didn't know at the time
I didn't know you don't I didn't I
didn't have the knowledge at the time
right knowing what I know know now I
would have started [__] around with
test at probably about 32
33 in your 20s you should be if
everything's normal you should be making
a lot you should be going to the gym and
working out and [__] making gains and
looking looking better and
growing now there's caveat to this if
you're a professional
athlete you're going to be working hard
and making a lot of money I'd have been
juicing into my [__] early 20s late
teens yeah there's ways you can do it
then now you're going to get popped in
sports for using it but they all use it
anyway they usually train in the off
seon under the influence of testosterone
and other antibi I when the games start
they come off of that then they start
going through the drug testings and
there's ways to come off to keep
everything running right and then you go
through the normal games you made those
gains and all that physical progress in
the off
season not during the game season that
way you don't get popped for the
drugs but you got bigger and stronger
you're making enough testosterone Dr
normally to support the gains that you
made in muscle mass that you built in
the offseason while you were under the
influence of [__] bumped up
testosterone and maybe nandrolone and
[__] like that they all do it I heard
that even professional bowlers are on
steroids now why would you need to be on
steroids there's something about [__]
they just say that it makes you more
attuned to your body it's a better mind
muscle connection I guess and that they
do better on steroids and they're not
testing for steroids but I've heard that
Bowlers take
steroids probably just not very a lot
some you
know I don't know what they're saying
might be anavar that's kind of funny
anavar always made me feel [__] like
really [__] jacked and Powerful I'm
driving and I feel like I'm oh man but
you don't really see anything on the
scale or in the mirror it just makes you
feel better you know yeah I didn't feel
jack [__] on that I I didn't feel any
different but like I said we've talked
about that weird with her I yeah I'm
what do they call it a non-responder
she's a
low a low responder I'm one of those
[__] and it's with all medicine
pretty much not just not just
androgens yeah it's just medicines um I
have like a really high pain
tolerance um I have a really good immune
system I hardly ever get sick with
anything and it's just I've always been
like that which is like really weird and
like drugs don't hardly do anything yeah
and I was giv her the normal
female Doses and types of anabolic
steroids namely
anavar then it went on a prima bowl and
some wistw there was just no response
none I didn't feel any different at all
no I I put her on man steroids and then
there it went 19 Nor testosterone that
was the first thing like yeah made any
difference she just went became super
Superwoman she looked like galado
do yeah like I said they're all on [__]
too I immediately lost what like 20 30
pounds yeah and then got more shapely
yeah her asses looking so [__]
good
yeah yeah just well Deca is known for
increased physicality yeah now
look I'm not a doctor and I'm trying to
[__] do a bunch of disclaimers right
there right here I say I'm not a doctor
don't do this don't take any of this
[__] okay um not everybody's the
same I went and by the book and there
was no response with her started doing
things a little bit more on the darker
side and the instant response because
not everybody's the same yeah everybody
has slightly different DNA they're
they're different ages so their your
hormonal properties are different your
endrin system is a little bit different
eventually you just got got to work
until you find something you respond to
that's all that's that's I'm an alien
clearly you're like an alien I always
kind of thought that when I was yeah
when I was growing
out I was like well I'm clearly not from
this planet I don't know what's going on
yeah she responded to man male [__]
test male [__] level steroids at male
doses basically she responded to
that like it takes a lot to it took a
lot yeah cuz you just give me that
little wimpy [__] and it's just kind of
my body's like me yeah I'm not even
seeing it got her rolling though she's
nowhere near what she used to be on but
it got it rolling yeah the body
recognized it and knew what to do with
it so I'm going to take a way down next
couple months well and like I said I
never thought of myself as like super
doodle or anything like that but I guess
I'm not super fi either just something
about your breeding I've seen her mom
all right her mom is in her 70s and she
looks like a kind of a youngish padora
if you know who pador is she used to get
a lot my mom yeah she does look lot and
she doesn't look like she's in her 70s
she looks like she's in her
50s so she's going to age well but I
think that there was just something
about her her her her metabolism just
didn't really respond to much of
anything real slow like I said I'm kind
of a freak of nature I don't really know
what to tell you
I don't really know what to tell you I
don't know myself you know I don't know
what the deal is I just kind of like Let
It Roll you know Jeffy art said have we
ever seen Gerald's Game on Netflix yeah
it's great uh Bruce Greenwood is in it
uh in his 70s and he looks smoking I bet
he's on tea yeah I think he probably is
I don't remember if you watched it with
me it's a Stephen King adaptation it's
good though do you I and I read the book
like a long time ago it's the one about
okay I don't remember if you watch this
with me or not but it's the one where
it's the older husband and the slightly
younger wife and they go to this um kind
of honeymoon thing to like rekindle
their relationship or whatever and
they're going to do some BDSM and he
handcuffs her to the bed but then he has
a heart attack and dies dies so she's
like stuck there yeah yeah yeah yeah
remember yeah yeah yeah I don't remember
that particular guy I that's a good it's
a good M I didn't remember him being I
don't remember that guy being an old man
so now that you're meres and yeah he
would yeah yeah test is one of the ones
you want to use you you have to have
that as at least a base to do primary
functions and
[__] some guys can't take a lot of that
there's side effects so what you do is
you come down on test you replace it
with something less androgenic which is
steroids which are is testosterone with
a lot of
the the side effects removed from it
people think that steroids are something
that are just made in a base bement it's
like something elicit and it's some kind
of chemical no it's testosterone it's
just that it's been generated
synthetically and they've removed a
couple of the the carbon atoms from from
the molecule and those carbon atoms are
the ones that kind of initiate secondary
male sex characteristics in other words
hair growth around the face and
deepening of voice and that way you
can you can use them for healing
purposes to heal up women and children
without turning them into man into men
that's what they're for steroids are not
to make you big that's another [__]
thing that people think that you take
steroids you get big no they were never
intended for that they don't really do
that what they do is they speed healing
in a normal human beings he healing is
done by with testosterone and
progesterone they speed
healing mostly testosterone
though you can't give that in large
quantities to a woman who's been burned
up you'll turn her into a man though but
so they have a synthetic copy of
testosterone that has those male side
effects removed from it so you can give
her that well if you're working out
normally you might only be able to work
out once you get pretty big you might
only be able to work out once a week
take forever to heal all that [__] up
because all that's a lot of muscle
tissue but if you inject steroids you
heal up faster so that means you can
work out four times a week five times a
week and
hard you know when I'm [__] on cycle
on good [__] I'll go and [__] work
myself to the Bone and you know 16 hours
later I'm totally healed up and another
five on top of that another six on top
of that I'm [__] actually slept and
grown and gotten
bigger that would never happen without
steroids it would take especially at my
age when you don't make a whole lot of
testosterone I started off naturally i'
work out and it would never really heal
up be in bed going oh God oh cuz you
just couldn't eat enough and couldn't
make enough testosterone to heal up
you'd only be able to work out maybe
like once every two weeks that's how
long it took to heal up [__] I work out
every day if I wanted to it's better
more like two or three times a
weak because you can heal up and grow
get bigger go the
rest Zach says uh one wonders how many
men my age now have body image issues
after growing up and seeing nothing but
super Jack dude in Marvel
movies yeah that's the thing and I I
kind of feel like um finally dudes are
getting a taste of like what women have
put up with all this time but and the
thing you have to think too is that I'm
not saying that a lot of the dudes like
the superhero dudes in the Marvel movies
don't look like that because they do
obviously they're jacked and everything
like that but one thing you have to
remember is one they're super rich um
they can afford nutritionists and
trainers and all that other kind of and
whatever drugs and also movie magic I
mean obviously they're going to do some
post- production on that stuff and like
kind of make it look better and [__]
like that so that might be not entirely
like what those people look like too so
you have to think of that it's kind of
the same thing as um you know you see
all the what they used to say like a
long time ago it's like oh all these
models and stuff like that like on the
covers of magazines but that that [__]
is like Photoshop to [__] like that is
not remotely what the original photo
looks like not saying that they don't
look good naturally because they do but
man the [__] that they do to those
photos they like slim their thighs they
slim their waist they lengthen their
neck they do like all this other kind of
stuff to like to make them look better
they don't really look like that you
know what I mean who I'm just saying
like generally when you see images in
the media yeah like on magazine covers
and stuff like that they don't entirely
look like that that's been photoshopped
but you're looking at those Jack dudes
like like on the Marvel movies and [__]
older guys that's all test test in
steroids uh people and like I said they
have the money and time to have like
trainers and nutritionist and all that
other stuff too which regular ass people
like us don't what that guy that Play
Thor Chris Hemsworth his name no no no
um who the guy that plays Thor Thor yeah
what's is name Chris something Hemsworth
is it is his name uh maybe I don't know
I've seen pictures of the guy he looked
good from the waist up but don't look at
his legs he's got the [__] worst legs
ever man that's what I mean they do some
of them like
they do look good yeah naturally but
obviously they're going to like they're
not bodybuilders amp that up like for
the movie too they're going to do like a
lot of post-production like special
effects and [__] like that yeah well
they're it's also steroids Chris Chris
is skipping leg day he didn't have leg
day his [__] legs are little scrawny
little calves and [__] but he's got a
decent upper
body
um but he's on gear and he's [__]
doing bench presses and [__] arm
curls you know pull-ups and uh in 18
months man you can get [__] big
pretty big if you're on that [__]
because you can work out almost every
day every other day and grow especially
if you're eating eating a lot you got to
eat a lot people forget that they don't
realize how much those guys eat because
you can't put on fat when you're on that
[__] everything just synthesizes it
you're just a protein synth synthesis
machine
if I'm on cycle man I can eat anything
you won't gain any fat you'll gain
muscle you won't gain any fat you'll
burn
fat Allison said sometimes on those pcks
they [__] up and put in an extra arm or
something yeah I have seen some of those
like bad Photoshop ones where it's just
kind of like the angle is like super
weird or the arm looks like distorted or
some [__] like that it's like man I hope
they fired the graphics that that did
that Jeffy got Chris Hemsworth yeah yeah
as Thor Chris Evans played Captain
America too many too many chrises he
looked good the guy that did Thor he
looked pretty damn good um he was doing
full body training
legs upper body he was doing
core and
uh I know the suit the suit that they
put him in has extra muscular to it yeah
um to make him look even bigger but he's
still and like I said SE him just
walking around photographs of he he's in
good shape he's in real good
shape I mean it's always easier to start
with somebody that looks pretty damn
good to start with but something like a
Marvel movie that costs like a 40
bajillion dollars um they're obviously
going to do a lot of uh CGI on that
stuff to like improve to like touch it
up you know what I mean but it's always
better to like start out with something
but you see them on talk shows and [__]
[__] no they look good yeah like G
Gau does look gorgeous she she's
gorgeous she's got a fantastic body is
that natural f [__] no no no she's on
gear probably a
lot well yeah that's what I mean it's
like so in some ways I feel like for
ordinary schlubs don't you can't
necessarily compare yourself to like
celebrities and stuff because one they
have like a [__] ton of money um they
have the time trainers to yeah trainers
nutritionists all this other kind of
stuff they have access to the best
anabolic drugs and [__] all the
hormone blockers and when they're put in
movies they get CGI
abely
that Luxy like nobody is going do for me
like I don't have trainers or
nutritionists or have somebody CGI in my
ass to like make me look like the best I
could possibly look yeah now somebody
might ask me well can can I do that you
know can I do and I'd have to say
probably not no probably not
because this is well known in the gym
scene [__] I he can attest to it I
know he's Natty I think he said he did
do cycle
dball some of the most [__] up people
you'd ever see in the gym are on a [__]
ton of gear but they they don't respond
to
it nothing really happens with them just
because you're on that [__] doesn't mean
it will happen there's a genetic
component if your genes are not right to
do
that you're just not going to you won't
respond to those drugs I mean everybody
can look better you can look better but
you won't look but some people can't
look like I mean some for some people
like genetically it's just like
impossible okay everybody knows what
Arnold Schwarzenegger looks like or what
a lot of people know what he looks like
when he was in his late teens early 20s
when he was in his [__] Prime doing
Olympia they think well [__] if I inject
that bottle of steroids right there I'll
look like Arnold [__] no Arnold was
[__] did quite a bit of gear for a
long time and he was kind of uh uh a
[__] perfect
storm when you look at all those guys
that are make it to Olympia which is
like that's a steroid drag race that's
the [__] those are the [__]
bodybuilder beauty queens okay because
it's not a [__] sport man it's a it's
a
[__] it's like Mr Universe and Miss
Universe and Miss America it's a [__]
beauty pageant it's just a male beauty
pageant and you're in you're you're
going to [__]
Olympia knowing that this is a steroid
event it's a steroid drag
race if you were to take the amount of
steroids those dudes to take you would
not look like that if you were to do the
diet the exercises and everything that
those dudes did you wouldn't look like
that
probably you're only seeing the dudes
that passed all these
[__] basically
test it it boils down what it boiled
down to is a mixture of everything goad
here you come
on your stuff in the yeah Arnold had
fantastic
genetics well yeah he took the right
amount of [__] drugs he worked out
the right way he ate the right stuff but
it wasn't the same thing his competitors
took eight different things they worked
out slightly different it were they were
all tailored to that specific
guy if I were to if I were you were make
me young in my
20s back when Arnold was in his 20s and
put me on the same routine something
would go wrong I wouldn't be able to
keep up with his routine most most um
bodybuilders from Arnold's time said
that they couldn't keep up with him in
terms of that how much he worked out
they would they weren't able to to to
heal up as much um but there were guys
that that almost looked exactly like
Arnold that did half of what he did in
terms of workout and looked like
that yeah it's just Arnold had a certain
way you couldn't use Arnold's routine
and try to be like Arnold well like I
said genetics were involved like I said
I kind of feel like that's why and
people seem to understand that better
nowadays which I think is good because
look I mean when I was growing up I
always wished that I was like a tiny
little wispy ballet dancer type it's
genetics but obviously that didn't work
out um so
you you know I have the body that I was
given you just kind of have to like work
with what you got yeah you know which I
don't love that CU that wasn't really
what I wanted but you can't really do
much about it you know what I mean Jenny
was typical Southern which is stocky
medium
build short short stocky medium build
yeah I'm like a little short
[__] but so was I short little
legs short little arms small little
hands small little feet yeah it's just a
real huge ass huge thigh
yeah it's like a southern thing to be
built kind of like kind kind of like a
Mexican actually it's the way a lot of
Mexicans are built uh my little 5 foot2
ass yeah and you know I'm 5'6 so we're
short stocky people yeah um but Jen
responded real well to a certain 19 or
testosterone uh known as Deca
durabolin and uh she'd probably respond
well to regular durab Bal and also known
as [__] MPP I love MPP
make me cough on injection sometimes but
MPP I liked MPP better than Trend it's
like Trend without the side
effects yeah cuz we've talked about that
how you're not allowed to Tren anymore
yeah I know it was fun for you but it
was like miserable for miserable for
everyone around you I turned into a
chimpanzee [__] 85 pound 187b [__]
133% body fat [__] champan at least
she didn't tear my face off so there's
that wanted to kill everything that
moved not everything that moved just
wanted to kill most men yeah yeah it was
crazy it it was a crazy time come yeah
crazy you become kind of hyper masculine
in a bad way yeah [__] crazy that was
on that [__] for [__] too long too it
was on [__] for five [__] months five
[__] months yeah you're I said I
didn't know until after you'd gone off
it you didn't tell me any of that I was
okay for about 3 months those last two
months I was starting to get crazy and
crazy become the goblin yeah the goblin
off [__] saying all kind of crazy
[__] all kind of crazy [__] I kind of
wish I'd recorded it now yeah so I could
play it back for you like do you hear
this yeah okay it's time for us to go
Jim oh yeah [__] we probably should um
Allison said uh my mom something my mom
came from that peasant stock yeah yeah
yeah it's just kind of like I said I
don't know I I guess I'm kind of like
now that I'm old um I I'm kind of like
well I guess you just got to accept what
you're given even though it wasn't
really what I wanted or like my ideal
like body type would be peasant stock is
short but if you work it man they put on
muscle because that peasants work
[__] you put on muscle you get get
good shape yeah I put on five pounds
that look on me on my skeleton five
pounds of muscle on me would look like
15 pounds on a [__] 6 foot2 dude yeah
you know I filled out fast yeah okay we
got to go all right so we got to head
out out cuz we got to drive to the club
takes about 28 minutes to drive there
and they're going to open at 10:00 so
we're going to head out so hopefully you
guys had a good time I had a good time
talking to you guys like I always do uh
thanks everybody for hanging out thanks
for your super chats we will see you
guys again o I might do a movie review
on Sunday I'm not entirely sure yet um I
did watch a wait further
instructions which um I think one of
y'all recommended I've been wanting to
see that for a while anyway so I finally
did watch it last night uh so I might
review it probably Sunday but we'll see
how that goes if I have uh time to do it
so if I don't see you on Sunday though
then we'll see you on Monday night for
the movie review so again thanks
everybody for dropping by have a good
Friday night have a good weekend and
we'll see you guys again uh later on
good night